this commanders of these drone squadrons
describe that it's actually more
difficult than commanding a traditional
manned squadron because of the
distancing but also there's the
challenge of being at war but also being
physically at home you know one of them
described to me that you would go in you
drive your Toyota Corolla into work you
get into the trailer and you basically
start carrying out a mission and for 12
hours you're taking out targets you're
hitting enemy combatants and then at the
end of the day you leave the trailer and
you enter back into America and you get
back in your Toyota Carolla and you
drive home and 20 minutes later you're
talking to your kid about their homework
at the dinner table and the result is
that the psychological disconnects have
proven very challenging and you actually
have higher PTSD rates among the drone
pilots than you do among many units that
are serving in places like Iraq and so
the officers in charge are trying to
figure out all sorts of different ways
you know how did they drive that home
how do they watch out for their men and
women who are fighting from afar they're
doing things like for example they have
to wear flight suits even though they're
not in the plane they wear the suit as
if they are all sorts of outside
communication is banned while you're on
mission you may be sitting 20 miles away
from your wife but no cell phone calls
for example and so they're constantly
saying you know what you may be
physically in Nevada but we're in Iraq
keep that in mind and lives are at stake
here